nato foreign affairs ministers are
meeting for a special summit on ukraine
it comes as allies tightened sanctions
on vladimir putin's inner circle at a
news conference with the u.s secretary
of state nato's secretary-general
condemned russian shelling on the
zaparica nuclear site as reckless
we condemn the attacks on
civilians and overnight we've also seen
reports about
the attack against nuclear power
this just demonstrates the
recklessness of this war and the
importance of uh
ending it and the importance of russia
withdrawing all its troops
and engaging good faith in diplomatic
efforts
every
ally
in one way or another is coming to
ukraine's assistance every ally in one
way or another is helping uh to
strengthen nato itself
and as the secretary general said ours
is a defensive alliance
we seek no conflict but if conflict
comes to us
we're ready for it and we will defend
every inch of nato territory
our diplomatic editor james baze is live
for us in brussels uh james another
meeting a flurry of meetings in the past
week what's happening today
well yes we've got nato
ministers meeting foreign ministers
they're joined by some other countries
sweden and finland which aren't nato
members
and the european union represented at
this meeting and then the other way
around in the afternoon when it will be
the european union meeting and
non-members of the european union like
the us and the uk
and the nato secretary general will be
meeting attending that meeting i think
the idea is to look at what they've done
so far and see if there's anything more
that they can do
clearly they've gone further i think
than many of the ministers thought they
would at the start of this conflict in
terms of sanctions
and i think they'll be looking at what
other measures they can take but you're
not going to see
these foreign ministers here at nato
doing what the ukrainian government
would want and that's to actively
support um
the ukrainians perhaps with a no-fly
zone a no-fly zone would need to be
enforced by nato aircraft we've seen how
that works in libya we saw how it worked
with kosovo um they will they would have
to be those nato aircraft potentially
shooting down russian aircraft then you
have a war involving nato and russia and
of course the us is a is a member the
biggest member of nato you then
effectively have a world war in world
war iii so that is something that they
will not countenance and i don't think
that is being suggested by any of the 30
nato members who are now meeting in
their closed meeting i think some though
of the nato members and particularly
those that are close to russia have
borders with russia are concerned we've
seen major reinforcement of those
countries in the last couple of weeks uh
but some for example the latvian foreign
minister on his way into the meeting
said it was time to go
from a deterrence mission to a
full-scale defensive mission now what he
means by that whether he wants even more
troops that's not clear but i suspect um
that many of the baltic states would
certainly like to see
that the presence of these troops
including us troops made more permanent
the the nato secretary general has
called the situation now the new normal
and in many ways uh you could divide
nato's history 1945 to 1989 was the cold
war 1989 until a couple of weeks ago was
phase two he now says we're in a new
normal which
some nato nations say will require
different position of of forces in the
future
james bay's diplomatic editor in
brussels thank you